MINE CETINKAYA-RUNDEL: Hello.
I'm Mine Cetinkaya-Rundel.
I'm a Data Scientist
and Professional
Educator at RStudio
as well as faculty
at the University of
Edinburgh and Duke University.
If you're also an educator
teaching data science,
you might find yourself
in the following scenario,
particularly this year.
Your department chair says,
your data science course
is going spectacularly.
We'd love to expand it.
And you say a big, yay.
But then they say,
oh, and you're
going to need to
do it all online.
And you say, yay?
And they follow up
with, and we can't
provide any additional support.
You get the same number
of TAs as before.
And you start
thinking to yourself,
am I supposed to say, yay?
As enrollments and
statistics in data
science courses grow,
and as these courses
become more and
more computational,
educators are faced with
an interesting challenge--
providing timely and meaningful
feedback, particularly
with online delivery of courses.
I'm sure we all agree that
feedback should be meaningful.
But traditionally,
meaningful, helpful,
constructive feedback requires
human effort and can take
a significant amount of
time for large courses,
especially if they're
under-resourced, which--
let's face it-- they tend to be.
Timeliness of feedback is just
as important as meaningfulness.
The longer time passes
between when a student turns
in an assignment and when they
get feedback on it, the lower
the utility of that feedback.
For certain assignments,
like an open-ended project,
this trade-off is
absolutely reasonable
because it's really
difficult, if not impossible,
to replace human feedback
with something else in such
an assignment.
But for others, there
are alternatives.
One such option is
a learnr tutorial.
And if you have ever
used learnr before,
the tutorial probably looked a
little bit different than this.
And that is just to say,
that with a little bit of CSS
and theming, you can make
your learnr tutorials
look like whatever you like.
I like starting my
learnr tutorials
with a bit of narrative, usually
a little bit longer than this,
about the data and
the analysis we're
going to work
through and introduce
the students to the packages.
And I like using the
progressive reveal option,
so they have to deliberately
click through the material.
I also like providing
some ready-to-run code
at the beginning.
So they don't need to
start working on exercises
right away, but they
do need to start
interacting with the document.
Here, they're working on a
data set on Airbnb listings
in Edinburgh.
And the first thing
we're asking them to do
is to take a look at
the variable names.
It is not necessarily
meaningful interactivity.
But maybe it introduces
them a little bit
to the structure of
a learnr tutorial,
and how to interact
with it, and potentially
also helps build a little
bit of anticipation
around what the result is going
to look like when they hit
Run Code, as opposed
to providing them
with a static document where
the code output is already
provided.
But really, where, a
learnr tutorial shines
are these coding exercises,
where the students can try out
some code, submit their
answer, and you can provide
custom feedback to them.
So the first exercise here
says, how many Airbnb listings
are included in this data set?
Let's imagine, the
student decided
to look at the number
of columns as opposed
to the number of rows.
The feedback that
they're going to get
sounds just like
the type of thing
I would say to them
if I was working
through the exercises with
them and trying to nudge them
in the right direction.
It says, did you calculate
the number of columns
instead of number of rows?
So you can write these
very precise feedback
based on your anticipation
about the types of mistakes
students can make.
And obviously, it's not
possible to anticipate
all possible mistakes.
So what if a student chooses to
try out some code that I didn't
anticipate they might try out?
For that, I like providing
some canned feedback that's
still constructive
and still nudges them
in the right direction--
says something
like, each observation is
represented in one row.
Can you remember which
function we use to calculate
the number of rows?
And finally, let's get
this question correct.
I'm going to use the
nrow function to do that.
Let's run our code
and submit our answer.
You'll see that we got the
green banner, which is great.
But it doesn't just
say, correct, well done.
It says a little bit more.
So I like using the
space for the message
for the correct
answers to give them
a little bit more information
about what's to come next.
So I also like following
on my coding exercises
with some multiple-choice
exercises, something
that allows the students to take
the code output that they saw
and put it in the context of the
data set that they're working
with, which is so important for
teaching statistics and data
science.
So what does each row in the
edibnb data set represent?
That's an individual
Airbnb listing.
And again, we can
use the feedback
to give them a little bit
more information or something
to think about.
If you would like to see
the code for this learnr
tutorial, both, in terms of
creating the exercises and also
the theme and the look, you can
test drive it on RStudio Cloud,
or you can view
the code on GitHub.
And I'll be providing
links to all
of this at the end of the talk.
For now, I'd like to talk
a little bit about writing
effective exercises.
So let's start with
an exercise in mind.
The three most
expensive neighborhoods,
in terms of mean nightly
price are New Town, Old Town,
and West End.
Calculate the median number of
reviews in these neighborhoods
and arrange them in
descending order.
One option would be to provide
no scaffolding, whatsoever-- so
an entirely empty canvas
for students to work with.
And the thing about this is
we've really not given them
any direction, in terms
of how to get started.
And instead, what we've given
them is this giant button that
says, Solution, and
it's so tempting
to simply go, all right, let
me take a look at the solution,
copy it to my clipboard,
paste it, run my code,
and submit my answer,
and lovely job.
I got it right.
But did I learn anything
from this experience?
Not really.
This is not to say your
students are all going
to peek into the solution code.
But I think one
thing to keep in mind
about providing no
scaffolding whatsoever
is that I think there are
better venues for giving
such exercises.
So for assignments where
the students already
have to work in the RStudio
IDE, either in an R Markdown
document or in an
R script, I think
is a better venue for a more
open-ended question where
you provide no
scaffolding, whatsoever.
Here, we've given
them no scaffolding.
And we've also done
something else,
where we basically are doing
this strict code-checking
business.
So let's say that your student,
with no scaffolding provided
to them, actually decided to
move the filter over here.
They group by and summarize
first, and then they filter.
And if they run
their code, they're
going to get the
exact same response.
But their code is not
marked as correct.
Because with the
grade_this_code() function,
what is happening under the
hood is that the gradethis
package is checking the
code your student wrote
and the solution code
you provided and looks
for a one-to-one match.
So it says that I expected
you to call summarize
where you called filter.
Give it another try.
Sure.
You might say that, no,
this is exactly how I
want my students to do things.
But I think that's not
really entirely fair,
especially because they
actually got the right answer.
So the strict code checking
with no scaffolding whatsoever
can lead to situations where
students get the right answer
but are not necessarily
marked correct, if you will.
Another option
would be to provide
a little bit of scaffolding.
But here, we're still
doing this strict check.
So here, we've given them
a really nice structure
for how to write their code.
And obviously, we've made the
exercise a lot easier for them.
But that might be OK if this
is one of the first few times
they're seeing these
multi-line dplyr chains.
So these learnr tutorials
are a great place
to provide additional
opportunities
for drill-type exercises
students can work through
at the beginning
when they are first
introduced to a new topic.
And you can also
provide hints for them.
So with these hints--
let's take a look at that--
I like writing them in
a progressive way, where
they can scroll through and get
a chance to potentially think
about what their answer should
look like at each stage.
And sure, they
could, at the end,
see the solution if
you want them to,
but at least it makes them
think along the way as well.
So let's go ahead and run this
code and submit the answer.
I think, in this
structure, there
is no worry that they would
be putting their filter
function later on
because we had already
provided the scaffolding.
However, since we're
doing a strict check
what if the student,
in the last line,
forgot to actually put
things in descending order.
So let's go ahead
and run that code.
And obviously, this is
not the correct answer.
But the feedback
that we get tends
to be not very informative
when we use the Grade This
Code function here.
So it's basically
saying, I expected
you to call desc for descending
where you wrote median writing.
And in fact, here on line five,
that statement is correct.
But does it actually
sound like the type
of thing you would
say to your student
if you were standing
right behind them
and trying to nudge them
in the right direction?
Not really.
It doesn't seem like very
human-friendly feedback.
So my recommendation,
overall, would
be to provide some
scaffolding and also provide
some flexibility.
This is another
approach to scaffolding,
where, perhaps, if this tutorial
is coming later on, if they've
already done a bunch with dplyr,
and you don't want to give them
that whole structure, you
might at least give them
a little bit of
scaffolding to say, hey,
I want you to use a dplyr
pipeline for answering
this question.
And let's go ahead
and give that a try.
So here, I am going to forget to
put things in descending order
and run my code.
And let's take a look at
the feedback that I get.
I actually am getting
human-friendly feedback here.
"You've have successfully
calculated the median number
of ratings, but did you
forget to arrange them
in descending order?"
How did I do this?
Here, instead of
checking their code,
we're actually checking their
result. And one nice thing
about doing that is--
so let's go back and put
the right answer here.
What if they made that one
change, where they were doing
Group By and Summarize
and then filter,
let's have them run the code
and submit their answer.
And in fact, this time,
it is marked as correct
because, again, we're checking
the result and not the code.
So what does this look
like under the hood?
It's a bit more to
write the code checking
if you're using the Grade This
function because you actually
need to think about what are the
various answers they might get,
and actually write some pass_if
or fail_if type statements.
So here, I have one
pass_if statement that
says if their result
is this tibble
in this particular order,
we're going to say, yep,
you did the right thing.
But if they have put
them in ascending order,
then we're going to give them
a specific message for that.
Or if they have not
ordered them at all,
in which case, the order will
be the alphabetical order
of the neighborhood, we're going
to give them another message.
And you can imagine stringing
along as many of these
as you think are relevant for
the exercises you develop.
And then, probably, you want
to write a catchall statement
that's like, not quite.
Take a peek at the hints.
If the students are making
mistakes that you can't even
anticipate when you
write the tests,
you can leave the hints
to take care of that.
And if you use these tutorials
over multiple semesters,
or multiple workshops,
multiple learning or teaching
engagements, you're
probably going
to learn about the
various mistakes students
make based on their questions.
And then you might
iteratively build
these tests to capture more
mistakes that they might make.
So we've talked about
writing these exercises.
What about collecting data?
Learnr and gradethis
alone don't
have some facility to allow you
to collect data from students.
Specifically, the learnr
package makes this possible,
but it doesn't itself offer
the functionality to do so.
So for that, I use a different
package called learnrhash,
which hashes the student
results and then allows you,
as the instructor,
to decode them.
So a setting where
I might use this
is probably similar to
this, where I give them
a coding exercise first.
It says, make a
histogram of the prices.
So let's go ahead
and actually do that.
The data set is edibnb.
The variable is price.
We're going to have
them make a histogram.
And here are the labels, x--
whoops-- y, and title,
maybe something like this.
They go ahead and
run their code.
And they get some warnings
and submit their answer.
It says, you got it right.
And note that there are
a couple of warnings.
We'll get to those
in a little bit
because here, our focus
is a little bit different.
So we follow this on with some
multiple-choice questions.
Which of the following describes
the shape of the distribution?
It's right skewed and unimodal.
And let's go ahead and
pick another answer
for the second question.
This one happens
to be incorrect.
OK?
So when it comes time to
submitting their answers,
with the learnrhash
package, students
can generate a
hash, which is going
to look very cryptic to them,
which is exactly what it's
meant to do.
They can select it and copy it.
And then I like
embedding directly
into the learnr tutorial
something like a Google form
or another form your
institution might use,
where the students can
submit their information.
If you're using something that
directly your university uses,
for example, this form could ask
them to authenticate for first
if you want to make sure that
who is answering the questions
is actually who you think it is.
And you can ask them
to paste their hash
that they generated here.
And I also like using
this form to collect
some free-form information
from the students as well.
So a question phrased as, write
about one or two questions
you didn't get right
initially but were
able to solve after a few tries.
What was difficult about them?
What did you ultimately learn?
And let the students write
some free-form answers
and submit their results.
On your end, what
you're going to see
is this hash that the
students have submitted.
And you'll be able to decode
that and be able to take a look
at their multiple-choice
questions,
and the answers they gave for
those, and the exercises--
that's the coding exercises--
and the answers they
gave for those as well.
For some of the
feedback for grading,
I usually tend to just mark
the multiple-choice questions,
but you could choose to do both.
These data are collected
in a Google spreadsheet,
so you can view the
Google spreadsheet itself.
I've pre-populated it with
some mock student data.
And what you can do is, using
the googlesheets4 package,
get that data and calculate
the student scores
by matching their
answers to a key.
And then also take a look
at the free-form answers.
I like taking a look at
bigrams, for example,
to see what are some concepts
that were mentioned many times
as being difficult
for the students,
so you might tailor your
next lesson accordingly.
Lastly, let's talk about
distributing these at scale.
One option, obviously,
is to deploy these
to something like shinyapps.io
or another shiny server
from the RStudio IDE with
push-button deploy just
clicking on Publish.
It works out of the box.
It's great.
But something you might
want to be careful about
is that if you have a large
class and a strict deadline,
many students
might try to access
the tutorial at the same time.
So you got to make sure that the
parameters for your deployment
are set up properly in order
to be able to handle that.
You might want to
give it more memory.
create more instances.
And at some point, if you
have a really large course,
and you expect students to be
doing things at the same time,
you may need to think
about using one of the paid
tiers of shinyapps.io.
And that may or may not be
feasible for your setting.
So another option is
to distribute them
within a package.
Here, I'm going to give an
example from the dsbox package,
which accompanies the Data
Science Course in a Box
curriculum.
And yes, I am saying that
you can make an R package.
And you might be
new to doing that,
so you can use this as
a skeleton for doing so.
But the nice thing is, really,
what you want to focus on
is that the tutorials
go in the inst folder
in a subfolder called
tutorials of the package.
Inside that is a single folder
for each one of the tutorials.
This package happens
to have eight of them.
And inside that is
the R Markdown file,
where you developed your
tutorial and any accompanying
files that go along with it.
Chances are, you may not want
to put this tutorial on CRAN.
Maybe it's not for
wide distribution.
But you can ask your students
to install it directly
from GitHub.
Or if you're using something
like RStudio Cloud,
you can ask them to--
you can pre-install it for them.
And within the
RStudio IDE, they will
be ready to be launched soon as
the students start that RStudio
session.
I usually tell my students
once you launch the tutorial,
just make that tutorial
pane, maximize it,
and it looks just like
they're interacting
with it within the web browser.
But now, you're not relying
on a service like shinyapps.io
be hosting your tutorial.
So it really doesn't
matter how many students
are using it at the same time
as long as you're RStudio
and allows that.
The barrier to entry for
getting started with learnr
is pretty low, especially if
you're already an R Markdown
user.
In fact, the tutorials
in the dsbox package
were co-developed with
students with only one
semester of introductory data
science under their belt.
So when I say it has a low
entry point, I really mean it.
We all know that students
get better at coding,
or whatever they're
learning, with practice.
We also probably mostly agree
that formative feedback that
nudges learners in
the right direction
while they're working on
the exercises as opposed
to summative feedback that
comes weeks after they're done
can have positive effects on
their learning and enjoyment.
Plus, providing
individual feedback
to students, especially for
exercises narrow in scope,
can turn into dreadful
busywork for us educators.
So while developing
meaningful automated feedback
can be quite tedious
and time-consuming,
I think that's a much more
intellectually engaging way
to spend your time
as an instructor.
It's also a great opportunity
to develop software engineering
skills, like writing
robust tests,
bringing together your
pedagogical and technical
expertise.
You can find materials
for this talk,
including the source code for
the learnr tutorial we worked
through and links to
resources to learn more
at rstd.io/global2021/mcr.
Thank you for watching.
And remember that comment from
your chair about no more TA
support?
With what learnr, gradethis,
and learnrhash can offer,
you might get closer to
responding, bring it on.